how do you so what do you do you melt
that gold down right yeah and then you
re-stamp it with your own stamp and then
you're good yeah it's yours that's clean
you wash the gold hey that's a good one
[Music]
recently there was a giant gold Heist at
Canada's biggest airport oh goal wait
what gold at the airport the Lufthansa I
heard about this yeah Canada's national
police force is investigating a heist at
Canada's busiest airport that may have
netted thieves more than 100 million
dollars worth of gold 100 million that's
a heavy amount
with Bitcoin you can just send it
through the air boom but with gold it's
so [__] heavy like it doesn't make
any sense to hold it does it in The
Italian Job
armored trucks all right let's check out
they used Mini Coopers no yeah oh yeah
they did Royal Canadians I didn't make
it to that party three of them with
special suspension you're racing plugs
you're raising bugs when that movie came
out the Royal Canadian mounded police
confirmed they are looking into a gold
robbery at Pearson International Airport
those [__] on horses looking
for gold yeah I do imagine they actually
get some gold gotta get a [__] hippo
to bring it back yeah so they mined the
gold in Canada gold binding other
animals
Canada doesn't have our kind of
technology
is it what's the plural of moose is it
really meat it's me I don't believe that
I looked it up is it really me yeah I
feel like we've had this if there's like
a herd of them it's a bunch of meats
yeah
sometimes hey you said 100 million yeah
it's about it's one gold one wait
1 428 kilograms holy [__] wow well that
doesn't mean anything to Americans bro 3
600 pounds that's about 3 000 pounds how
many liters is
stop speaking British it's uh 3 600
pounds how many milligrams let me let me
do articles I think Anthony knows it
already Joe how much is that in stone
yeah
3148 baby three thousand roughly roughly
100 wait so is the method in there the
method of how they did it no because
they can't give any information because
they haven't is there a picture of the
gold someone copycat people did they
really use mooses to move it or me I
love movie [__] in real life yeah we
need two you're like what though except
for things like the saw by the way I
don't like that kind of movie stuff
that's not what I mean that's a hot take
yeah the only correct plural of moose is
Moose
ah now you're on this whack website no
you're on Google you're on WebMD go bro
yeah
cheese moose and meese duck and fleece
poos and peas yup
a herd of moose of mooses is nice yup is
a flock of mice I don't think so anyways
flock of me the airport did not respond
to a request for comment uh basically 3
600 pounds of gold being moved through
the airport had been stolen that was
likely linked to organized crime [__]
yeah in Canada we're big fans they got
Canadian Mafia oh they got Vancouver
tryouts or maybe our people went up
there they'll be tired Italian because
someone's all is an American job
they don't steal in Canada they're so
nice how do you steal 3 600 pounds of
gold you just gotta have a [__] tell
us a welder thing go like this
so sick and then they got a vehicle
waiting right now but then remember but
they could they can measure through
security cameras the tire pressure to
see which one has the you know I think
about that at least once a day oh I'm
driving hey I already I already know how
it is you take all the gold you make
them look like Toblerone bars get it
through freaking uh duty-free come on so
were they was like the bank transferring
this gold and then it got intercepted
yeah it says gold mining Canada can
travel through Pearson on its way to
customers around the world oh it was
apparently gold that was mined in Canada
I like that that much gold doesn't have
like a dedicated guy watching it and
they just put it in a truck they spank
the truck's ass
all right we got him or that dedicated
it's 100 million
I built that gold down right and then
you re-stamp it with your own stamp and
then you're good yeah it's yours that's
clean you wash the gold hey that's a
good one oh [__] pretty easy to melt
gold it's really easy and you could bend
it pretty good too so how would they
know it's their gold yeah does you got
to bite it to check is that a thing yeah
is that just the moves it could Bend
yeah because if it's like real gold like
24 Karat plus then it's super malleable
you would be able to bend it yeah if
it's from the gold mine then they
refined it down to just 24. wow
I don't know anything about gold I love
gold it's like fiction to me have you
ever panned for gold before no it's
pretty fun seeing those videos on
YouTube can't stop watching dude it's
the most there's nothing more boring on
the earth you don't get nothing you
don't get [__] you get like a dust and
then when you do gets like this after
being out there for like all day with
your dad or whatever and he's just
sweating too you do get something and
then you ask people how much it's worth
and they're like it's probably worth
like four dollars and you're like
that surprises your quality time with
your dad huh [__] hey dude I at least
want a profit off of this I love those
gold bass gold mining channels though
like they'll get like a nugget like this
and they're like oh my God and then it's
like they don't tell you though they
spent three months I like those Cobalt
mining videos dude I've been seeing this
one guy who lives he's in Amsterdam and
he has this giant like uh magnet and in
the waters he just throws it oh yeah the
guy oh he pulls out the bike he pulls
out bikes he pulls out safes I know he's
not gonna get anything cool but you're
just like you know what the part you
know the part of the video you don't see
is him throwing it in
[__] bike I'm like that is a perfect
Bike Dude that guy Chuck he just bought
it they found they found the owner yeah
dude there's some girl that Bell still
works
cheating on it too dude but it's funny
because like so the the that one was
funny because clearly she was like yeah
I just parked outside a cafe and then
someone just shook
hey that is very European though if she
parked in the wrong place some [__]
was like the bike
get the [__] out of here dude I was
walking around and uh God I was in
Amsterdam or whatever and they have bike
lanes and these guys are [__] about
it dude like that's probably an [__]
because I was walking like in the bike
lane but then this guy's like coming
around me he's like [__] you and I was
just like [__] were you wearing this
outfit though nah I wish I mean that's
how they treat bike Lanes out here too I
wasn't dripping back though yeah you
weren't dripping not like that you know
anybody from the angry bicyclist
community
no because all the ones I encounter
They're All Dead dude
they're all six feet under my thing is I
hate them though I hate them back
you know what I mean yeah
yeah big time I'm gonna make a John Wick
movie where like I'm John Wick but
instead of killing the bad guys he just
fights cyclists
and he's just doing gun food to those
guys just endless waves of cyclists I'm
just being all unarmed that's one of the
few things that American audiences could
all agree on I think [__] bicyclists
and it's the guys with the [__]
they're serious they got the glasses and
the tires aerodynamics yeah we're not
talking about the guys on the [__]
little Cruiser
aerodynamics you can go seven miles an
hour in your little bike little [__]
yeah but the worst thing is shaving your
[__] body for that have you ever been
going up like like uh like Mulholland or
like a Canyon Road and they're in this
you're stuck oh they hold up like dozens
of cars yeah that's insane if I'm the
cyclist that's doing that I have an
immense amount of like anxiety and guilt
for doing that like pull over to the
side you have to replace that with
entitlement that makes me want to carry
around like a recreational amount of
[__] gravels
[Laughter]
all you need is a little cane so you can
pop pop tires yeah dude you just need a
little cane to [__] put in the rim
dude a little bit
I do have those little moments where
because we you know we do JK and stuff
so I read more news than I normally
would but then there's little moments
where I see like an article where it's
like cyclist was struck and killed and
I'm kind of like yes
it's a little moment I have
started licking his lips yeah I have a
little moment with myself that's all I'm
gonna say
that's a wishing cyclists just pain
trauma and death no that's not what
we're saying oh
no oh wow out loud we don't wish that
out loud
not all of them
just a mean one I didn't miss the part
where we was talking about watching
Cobalt miners
yeah love those live streams some random
people from JK have been sending me like
videos of cops reprimanding cyclists
have you guys seen those ones
they're they're pulled over and the cop
is just like yeah I'm talking to you
[__] like just talking [__] to these
guys and it's so funny because they are
very entitlement is very strong you know
you know who like this is not a hot take
because I hope you guys will all agree
with me the number one person who should
be wiped from the planet are those
people that go to police departments and
start filming everything to try to start
[__] that they can just talk about their
rights I have a right to be here I have
a right to film I'm performing business
just to like waste everyone's time I'm
performing official business I love
those guys dude hey you know what I
randomly started watching it's kind of
funny though you heard of uh cart marks
I love Cardinals what's Cardinals
that's almost a satire Cardinals it's
hilarious it's the guy that goes around
different parking lots around the world
and if people don't put their cart back
in the thing he acts like he's a cop for
cart
yeah she goes excuse me ma'am why did
you put your cart back what is this like
and then it just makes a big [__]
deal people lose their [__] people get
really defensive off on him they get mad
really [__] and if they try to drive
away he has like a magnetic bumper
sticker that says something about like I
didn't put my car back
he shames dude look it up cart marks
it's ridiculous he gets into some [__]
I'm sure that I I didn't know that was
so big but you know did you notice that
like so he's funny because he has kind
of like a dorky white guy Vibe so he's
non-threatening right now yeah but then
some people are trying to copy him now
and they're going Hood with that [__]
and it's not good oh [__] yeah they're
just too mean he's scary yeah they're
looking he's not hardcore enough we need
to go be confrontation exactly They're
copying his thing but it's it's not the
same like this guy's like a Ned Flanders
guy oh it's kind of funny you know
[Music]
foreign